we have great leadership here that
understands that uh one mistake
can uh be our demise
um one mistake can bring us all down in
in a real bad way and it's not just
coming to football it can create a
terrible illness so i want to dominate
when we leave the building we want to
crush this virus we want to beat this
virus into the ground
and i can use those words because it's
not on our schedule
the virus puts its pants on same way we
do john gruden says but look he's got
the right idea they need to take it
seriously and chris i think john gruden
when he's up at 4 00 a.m
pacific time
right what time is the show on the show
he could he could roll hello john
roll into the office and tune on nbcsn
or
siriusxm211 or sky sports if he has a
feed from the uk in ireland uh and check
us out and i you raised the point
earlier this week as we talked about
which teams would be best situated to
deal with a head coach being positive
during the season and not being
available to coach you need a dry run in
training camp and jay john gruden went
dry run during camp according to nfl
media they found out from special teams
coordinator and assistant head coach
rich pasachia who presumably would be
the guy to take over i would think so
john gruden had tested positive for
covet 19 and wasn't available
and it's it's you're gonna have to be
ready for it it's smart you know it was
kind of like yeah it's kind of a joke
it's kind of funny it's kind of a prank
no it's real because it could happen
it's one of the things you have to
simulate it's one of the things you have
to prepare for because any given day for
the entirety of the 2020 season this
could happen it could happen on friday
saturday it could happen game day and
you need to be ready for it they need to
have procedure in place for who's going
to take over and how it's going to go to
try to win the game if the head coach
isn't there right right and also with
the other thing it'll teach the players
to deal with the emotions of the moment
when it does come true right to not let
it become a distraction to where all of
a sudden a friday practice is ruined
because the whole locker room and guys
are just gossiping about it our coach
got covered our coach got coveted are we
gonna get it blah blah blah all of those
things that can distract the football
team let alone even if it happened on a
sunday morning the day of a game so
that's the the i think the genius behind
that and i think you know john you know
listen i'd love to take credit for this
idea but as i think i said on the show
earlier this week you know this is
something i had heard from coaches in
the nfl that they thought they would
throw some of these curve balls at their
assistants at some point during training
camp for this exact circumstance to see
how things are juggled around rich
basatia who's a hell of a coach i was
with him in tampa you know he is he's
perfect guy to be the head coach one of
the best special teams coaches in
football and yeah now it's a great
lesson for you know on you know down
down the path as far as the coaches are
concerned rich versace has got to coach
the special teams hey but rich now you
know now you're the head coach too so
you're gonna have to deal with some
players coming in to talk to you about
head coach type of things and you know
now rich you're gonna have to delegate
some responsibilities to your assistant
special teams coach because you're gonna
be doing head coach thing so you know
the the trickle effect i think is what's
really real there and what you got to
get used to and i think it's a good you
know a good ploy to get your team ready
for
just the distractions that could come
about in a year like we're about to go
into
other side of the coin you don't want to
do it too often or a chicken little
dynamic creeps in so when it happens for
real right the players are like oh come
on we've done this before don't don't
give me that don't give me that crap so
smart to be ready smart to have a plan
this is one of those years where again
everything you can identify that you
need to worry about you'll find
something else as you make that plan
what else do i need to be thinking about
oh there's this oh okay i'm thinking
about this well now there's another
question i need to resolve and and this
is a prime example of and it's not just
the head coach who could be gone yeah
you could wipe out all the coordinators
you could be down to the to the
assistant offensive line coach is the
only guy who's and that's and see we've
talked about whether or not a team
qualify for some sort of a de facto
postponement based upon having no
offensive lineman how many coaches do
you have to lose before the commissioner
would say we don't expect you to play
today yeah i mean that's that's a good
question and and i don't know where that
answer lies i mean i really don't you
know i i would i mean you lose your
offense a defensive coordinator you just
lose those two guys right as big of a
blow that is i don't think that's worthy
of canceling a game you still got other
coaches there so i would think would
have to take like you know a defensive
coordinator and then a few people on the
defensive staff to go down with him you
know and then and then okay it's the
offensive coordinator and a few people
on the offensive staff that go down with
him as well to where now the head coach
is calling the league going like listen
i got nobody here like no i have a a
first-year assistant offensive line
coach who's like 25 years old i can't
ask him to call plays today this is
gonna be a you know a major issue so i
know you're right that's it's something
we haven't really talked about or you
know dove into it all but
very real possibility and and i don't
know what that that line would be for
the nfl and the commissioner to say okay
that this is not good for the game
and coincidentally it happens just as
we're getting ready to play the kansas
city chiefs i mean that's the other side
of it that you have articulated the idea
that the teams have responsibility to
keep the virus out of the building and
engage in proper procedures and the mere
fact that it gets in and infects
multiple people
that is proof
that they've failed yes right right just
the result shows that somebody didn't
properly do what they were supposed to
do to prevent the spread of the virus so
if you get to the point where you feel
like you can't play because your
coaching staff is wiped out on one side
of the ball or the other is it a forfeit
i know or is it a no i try to make this
game up week 18. right i kind of like
i'm warming up to it
because yeah keep people stricken on
their game about like not getting sick
out off the field and being careless
there
even if
one guy brings it in if these mechanisms
especially among the coaches because
they're not out there in the scrum of 11
on 11 playing football or practicing
football if you have an outbreak among
your coaches if you have enough of an
outbreak that it just it's it's so much
that it just shows that there's got to
be some carelessness or it wouldn't come
to this point right i i think that i
think that you shouldn't be saved by
that and uh you know instead of having
somebody's record be seven and eight
instead of seven and nine you're just
seven and nine because it's on you yeah
it's on you to not be able to play
especially if teams start lobbying for
it you know you get a head coach on the
phone hey i got my i know i'm offensive
coordinator all my quarterbacks coach
and all my running backs coach and i'm
my receivers coach i'm down to a quality
control guy and i'm a defensive expert i
can't do it today okay fine you forfeit
yeah you know your players are healthy
you show up and play or you forfeit so
it's we just have to be ready for
anything just like the players have to
be ready for anything when it comes to a
coach possibly being unavailable at a
moment's notice the uh the fans have to
be ready
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports